taiwan is headed to presidential
elections in January next year but
allegations of election interference are
already being made no less than the
president of Taiwan has alleged that
Beijing is interfering in the election
process I'll be speaking to Taiwan's
Deputy Foreign Minister about those
allegations in a minute but Taiwan is
already taking action
it has detained a couple whose company
is alleged to be a front for Chinese
spying activities in Taiwan the Interior
Ministry is investigating if Zhang Xin
and his wife vouching were involved in
activities to interfere in the election
process a process that many in Taiwan
are claiming has long been a target of
Beijing's activities as elections go it
looks and feels like any other but
beneath the placards and noisy campaign
events accusations of foul play
persistent leveled by Taiwan's president
who is seeking a second term China is
using various means to intervene in
Taiwan's election to damage our
democracy as a large country
internationally and regionally they have
to take on the responsibility to
maintain regional peace and stability
early ID goes by in the tense atmosphere
of this vote without some mention of
their mighty neighbor whether you know
he's coming from the European
perspective or Australians or New
Zealand perspective Taiwan is the most
seriously affected by China's influence
operation there's no doubt about it
like this a 55,000 ton aircraft carrier
sailing through the Strait of Taiwan
last week a routine operation say China
an intimidation tactics say the
Taiwanese other aspects are less
conspicuous like what was going on
inside this Hong Kong office Chinese
espionage efforts according to the
explosive claims of a self-confessed spy
you know Taiwan was the most important
work on house the infiltration into
media the temples and grassroots
organizations China has dismissed him as
a thief and says Taiwan's interests are
best served as part of China I want to
say to Taiwan that we have been
cooperating in a friendly way with many
countries in the world based on mutual
benefits these benefits not only suit
China's interests but also other
countries interests it's a view shared
by the China friendly presidential
contender hon call you if he could
overcome the odds to win in January it
may not be entirely a mark of his own
success and for more I'm joined in the
studio by Taiwan's deputy foreign
minister dr. Zhu Jian Xiu dot shoot
welcome Taiwan is headed to presidential
elections next year on the 11th of
January and the current president
sanguine has already accused China of
attempting to influence this election
what proof is there of this well I think
from our experience of last election
last year we had a local election and
there are a lot of fake accounts on the
social media that boost certain
candidates and if we trace them the
their address changes day by day
sometimes is in Istanbul sometimes is in
Tokyo sometimes it's in Europe and so
there were a lot of these fake accounts
and eventually they play a very
important role in making big success for
certain candidates and also our ruling
party experienced defeat and we learn
from that so there are still this kind
of fake accounts that's one thing and
also they were a spread of
disinformation how can you be so certain
that these fake accounts just on this
particular point
driven by people in China over the
Chinese government of course from the
perspective my ministry Ministry of
Foreign Affairs we're not in charge of
investigating into these cases but I I
think a lot of people would have this
very legitimate suspicion because that's
the thing is it the deputy foreign
minister I mean what is suspicion the
other is proof so if statements are made
from the highest portals of government
accusing another government of directly
influencing elections you can see how
that is a cause for concern Asian if it
is just on the basis of suspicion and
not proof so of course there are texts
that were written in simplified Chinese
character and which is not used in
Taiwan we use the traditional ones in
their a certain way of the the way they
phrase things are different from what we
face in Taiwan so these are indirect you
may call it evidence or hints but I
think from the our Bureau of
Investigation they they have grasped
certain evidences that they in the China
side the Chinese side there were such
things called content form that has been
traced and they create certain kind of
disinformation contents and this content
will be copied in the social media group
in Taiwan in spread it to the mainstream
media so if China is active in spreading
disinformation and influencing the
upcoming Taiwanese election whom is
China trying to prop up there are
political parties social groups and
people in Taiwan that are more
sympathetic to this position of you
reunification with with China I think
these people or these groups are China's
target just just clarify to me what
Taiwan's position on reunification / one
China /
being a separate in entity is concerned
because we go back to the consensus of
1992 in which there was some agreement
on the term one-china but then the
current government of sighing when
appears to discard that and has a
different take so where exactly does
Taiwan stand right now it is not true
that in 1982
there was a consensus on one China in
1992 both sides met in Singapore and at
that time both sides agrees agreed that
there is only one China but the you know
different side we and them we can
express where we can describe what one
China means in our own way so that was
the so to speak agreement but that's
agreement to disagree because there is
second part however right now from the
Beijing side they take only the first
one that is only one China they discard
the second part right so actually no
consensus so we're looking at the first
part in a second part and I'm just
wondering in terms of the way forward
when there is disagreement along these
lines what is the way forward after the
elections the best way to solve any
disagreement in human society is through
talk so we we don't have any
precondition to have a talk with Beijing
and I think that will be the only
healthy way to solve our disagreement so
let me come back again it's not true
that we discard some agreements because
from our perspective there was no but we
leave it there for the time being doctor
switch and Xu thanks so much for coming
in thank you